claudine kamikaze has a precious
commodity that's in high demand
she runs a mobile solar kiosk at the
central bus station in the rwandan
capital kigali
many of the phone users are lighting
here have been on the road and offline
for hours
clothing's kiosk enables them to charge
up their phones or surf the net courtesy
of solar power
business is good i chose this because
it's something new
the fact that they always come to me
shows i made a good choice
the mobile solar kiosk is the brainchild
of henry nyakurundi
the idea was an obvious solution to the
situation on the ground he says
seventy percent of rwanda's eleven and a
half million inhabitants have a mobile
phone but only twenty two percent have
electricity
people spend a whole day here there's no
plug if you look around there's no plug
for people to charge so it's a
convenient way for people while they're
waiting for the bus to charge their
phone uh pay a small amount and then go
on on their business or whether we're in
uh
in rural area the convenience still the
same you know people don't have time to
carry the charger with them to go to a
store and having to ask somebody now
they can do that
it's been four years since nyakarundi
built the very first mobile solar kiosk
with the assistance of a german company
there are now 40 spread across rwanda
each one managed by independent
operators like claudine
a portion of their earnings goes to the
inventor
for him what began as a simple idea has
evolved into far more than just a
business model
the social impact
it's very um
key of our business
that's what we focus on
so we we mostly looking
for women people with disability
that don't have any jobs no other
opportunity
but wants to work and it's also bring
a certain i wouldn't say pride but
self-esteem
demand is substantial in rwanda both for
new jobs and for access to electricity
and the internet
which is why henry nyakarundi sees huge
market potential
by the end of this year he plans to
expand his pool of kiosks from forty to
between six and eight hundred
he also wants to take his invaluable
experience from rwanda and introduce the
successful micro franchising model to
neighboring uganda where the majority of
the kiosk components are made it's not
just creating jobs
through micro entrepreneurship but it's
building this ecosystem
that will support them through that
business so we transport the kiosk to
the location for them um which is
including on the fee we give them
support on the
uniform they wear they have an app
where they sell services
the mugambwa area is a three-hour drive
from kigali
most people here get around on foot
whether to go shopping pick up water or
reach the nearest generator or electric
socket
emmanuel gakindi set up business with a
solar kiosk three years ago it's the
original edition with no internet access
but people still come flocking wherever
he shows up
now i also have a paid assistant and i
can cover all my expenses from the phone
charging business
he's even added a second kiosk he'd also
like to provide internet access to his
customers which would require one of the
new kiosks
henry karundi is introducing the next
generation at the smart africa
conference at the kigali convention
center
it brings together politicians with
entrepreneurs donors and investors to
discuss technical solutions for the
continent and its people
henry nyakarundi is happy to see so much
interest in his innovation
our goal for the next actually 10 years
is uh
20 countries in africa we've already
selected the countries we estimated
about 50 to 100 000 kiosks
in all those countries that
that's about fifty two hundred thousand
uh micro businesses will be creating
a mobile solar kiosk currently costs
more than two thousand dollars
henry plans to maximize the number of
components made in africa lowering the
price and creating even more jobs
[Music]
claudine the kiosk operator from the bus
station has finished work for the day
now she's helping her children finish
their homework
she can more or less determine her own
working hours
and how much commission she earns from
the sale of phone credits and
electricity
and the job helps me to make ends meet
it's made things a lot easier
she earns around 100 a month from the
kiosk which in rwanda amounts to double
the average income